you're looking at what remains of a
thousand-ton
316-foot u.s navy warship that hasn't
been seen in over a century discovered
just last week by a team of british
divers the uss jacob jones commissioned
in 1916 was on the north atlantic during
the first world war when it became the
first u.s destroyer sunk by enemy fire
the find of the jacob jones is a big
deal to the u.s navy retired admiral sam
cox is director of the naval history and
heritage command in washington d.c
the uss jacob jones was called a
destroyer that's a type of ship
smaller than a battleship smaller than a
cruiser
very fast
very versatile in its mission
during that time of the war primary
purpose was to escort convoys
and defend the troop ships against
german submarine attack
but it was just that which the jones
fell victim to on december 6 1917 after
escorting a convoy to france the ship
was heading back to its home port in
ireland when it was attacked by a german
u-boat the u-53 was under the command of
capital lieutenant hans rose who was a
very capable
german submarine skipper and sunk 79
ships during the war
fired one torpedo at the jacob jones
which was very accurate
look outside of the torpedo the ship
almost was able to avoid it but not
quite the torpedo hit the jones near the
stern causing massive damage and
uncontrollable flooding one of the
sailors capturing the moment when the
ship went down out of the 110 man crew
only 46 were believed to have survived
including the rescued sailors in this
photo the ship settled in its final
resting place where it lay undiscovered
for 105 years
that is until a group of expert british
divers who spend their time searching
for shipwrecks and call themselves
darkstar set out to find the lost vessel
just last week after an 18-month search
they did ironically with the help of the
german u-boat commander's detailed
logbook the wreck of the jacob jones is
located about 60 miles off the
southwestern tip of england near the
english channel lying beneath 400 feet
of water and this is where it will
remain undisturbed in accordance with
international salvage law and a
widespread protocol for military wrecks
when a u.s navy shipwreck is found our
general policy is to leave it
undisturbed it's a war grave it's a
hallowed site
it's pretty incredible given the size
and depth of the ocean that they can
find anything like this but what what
great work i know and that they use that
u-boat commanders that yeah that log was
how they were able to help discover it
so so sensitive that they still
acknowledge that it is
a gravesite right it's a memorial to
them